[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
اذربيجان تصف الهجوم على سفرتيها
بالارهابي وتتهم ايران بتجاهل دعواتها
لتعزيز امن السفاره
روسيا تاكد استهدافها اسلحه غربيه وشنه
هجمات مكثفه على البنا التحتيه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا
تلقي القبض على قاتله المبدعه السعودي
والرابعه تكشف التفاصيل
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه الرابعه ايضا
اسواق الفقع في شمال السعوديه تشهد اقبالا
واسعا وحجم المبيعات الالاف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الدرعيه تستضيف اليوم وغدا ولا المره
الخامسه منافسات سباقات فورملائيه
حياكم الله وصفات
الهجوم على سفاره بلاده في طيران الذي ادى
الى مقتل شخص واصابه اثنين بالعمل
الارهابي وطالب بالتحقيق في الحادث
ومحاسبه المسؤولين في السياق قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الاذربيجانيه انها ستجلي موظفيها
في السفاره في طهران بسرعه وتامت ايران
بتجاهل دعواتها لتعزيز الامن في سفاراتها
بطيران اعتبارا الخارجيه الاذربيجانيه ان
الحمله المناهضه لباكو في ايران ساهمت في
الهجوم على السفاره
واظهر فيديو جديد متداول للهجوم على سفاره
اذربيجان في طيران اظهر لحظه وصول المهاجم
مسرعا على متن السياره قبل نزوله حاملا
سلاحا الرشاشا بعد ما اصطدم بسياره متوقفه
امام مدخل السفاره وينفيت الفيديو الى
تفادي المهاجم لحارس السفاره الذي كان
جالسا في غرفه امنيه والذي بدور لم يحرك
ساكن في لحظات الهجوم وسماح بدخوله دون اي
مقاومه او محاوله ابلاغ وهو الامر الذي
اثار الكثير من التساؤلات حول تفاصيل ما
جرى
[موسيقى]
اعراب الخارجيه السعوديه عن ادانتي
واستنكار المملكه للهجوم على سفاره
اذربيجان في طيران ودعت الخارجيه السعوديه
في بيان الى احترام حرمه البعثه
الدبلوماسيه ومعاقبه الجنات في الهجوم على
السفاره الاذربيجانيه بطهران
من لندن ينضم الينا الباحث في الشان
الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن سيد وجدان مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض يعني عندما تشاهد هذا الفيديو الذي
عرضناه قبل قليل عن هذا الدخول الثالث
الى داخل السفاره
اذربيجانين الا يمكن القول في حاله مثل
هذه الحاله بانه هجوم مدبر همم ليس هجوما
منفردا او عملا يعني تابعا ل همم لشخص
بعينه او حتى لمنظمه صغيره يبدا انه اكبر
من ذلك ليس كذلك سيد وجدان
تحياتي لك متابعي قناه العربيه الكرام دون
ادنى شاك بانه هذه العمليه هي عمليه مدبره
وايضا وهنالك بعض الروايات تفيد بانه
الوحده 400 تابعه لفيلق القدس الايراني هي
من تقف خلف هذه العمليه وايضا ثلاثه
جرى يفيد ويؤكد هذه الروايه همم لكنها ما
قد يكون افسد همم الخطه التي
رسمها
رسمتها الوحده التابعه لفريق القدس وهي
روايه بانه الشخص لديه مشكله وايضا كانوا
مع اطفال همم كانوا يظن منهم منه المجرم
يقوم بالعمليه ويستطيع القرار لكن احد
رجال الامن في السفاره ايجانيه بعد القبض
على المجرم اعتقد افسده كل الروايات
والدليل بانه شاهدنا همم سبق النظام
هذه عمليات مماثله ان كان فيما يتعلق
بموضوع السفاره وايضا القنصليه السعوديه
في مشهد وايضا السفاره البريطانيه همم في
كل حادث يحدث هكذا او اختلافات سياسيه
تحدث ما بين ايران
والدول
مثل المملكه او بريطانيا او اذربيجان يقوم
من النظام من خلال
ميليشاته وايضا المرتزقه بهكذا عملي
هذه العلاقه المتوتر
الامور ليست في افضل همم حالاتها كانت
ايضا همم يعني همم اذربيجان قد اتهمت
ايران اليوم وحتى ايضا في وقت سابق بانها
تتجاو- تتجاهل دعواتها لتعزيز الامن في
السفاره الاذربيجانيه او في محيطها ما
الهدف في هذا التوقيت من استهداف سفاره
اذربيجان من استهداف حتى سفارات الدول
التي ليست على الوفاق مع ايران تحدث عن
السفرات الموجوده في طيران
اولا لا ننسى منه المنطقه التي حدث فيها
هذه الجريمه همم هي تعتبر من اكثر المناطق
امنا اللي هي اا تقع السفارات وايضا مراكز
المخابرات وايضا كواجد القاده الامنيين
والحرس وقاده الحرس الثوري الايراني في
هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه همم هي همم
لديها تشدد امني كبير هناك لكن لماذا تم
استهداف السفاره لها اذربيجانه ياتي هذا
الامر على ضوء الاختلافات
والتوترات القائمه ما بين
ايران على عده نقاط منها العلاقه ما بين
اسرائيل
وتزويد اسرائيل
بمليارات من الدولارات
للسلاح له اذربيجان الموضوع الاخر هو
موضوع المعابر التي كان يستخدمها الحرس
الثوري الايراني والنظام لتهريب السلاح ده
روسيه عبر ارمينيا او الايجار بالمخدرات
عبر هذه الحدود بحيث قامت مؤخرا اذربيجان
بايجاد سيطرات خاصه في سيطره اللاجئين ما
بين ايران واذربيجان وصول وصولا لارمينيا
وتفتيش المركبات التي تنقل المخدرات او
قطع المسارات الامر الاخر ايضا همم
التواجد الاسرائيلي وايضا موضوع همم هروب
من يقومون بعمليات في الداخل الايراني الى
اذربيجان اضافه الى المسيرات التي تنطلق
من اذربيجان بعض المناطق داخل ايران منها
التواجد الاسرائيلي همم
يتسع بشكل اكبر له
استغلال بوجودك معي يعني للسؤال عن هذه
النقطه اذا سمعت اذا سمحت سيد همم وجداني
اذا كنت تسمعوني الا يمكن ان تكون او هذه
العمليه يعني منطلقا ل- اا محاوله تخريب
هذه
العلاقه وما تبقى من هذه العلاقه طبعا
الايرانيه
اذربيجانيه وان ياتي سحب السفراء
والدبلوماسيه من جانب اذربيجان وليس من
جانب طيران اولا
طبعا لان اذربيجان هي همم حذرت النظام
الايراني مسبقا بالنساء تحصل هنالك بعض
العمليات تجاه سفاراتها في ايران وغد تكون
لديها معلومات حول هذا الامر كما يبدو انه
كانت هذه المعلومات همم دقيقه همم بمعنى
انه همم هذا يؤكد روايه النظام خلف هذه
همم العمليه طبعا اذربيجان تسحب همم
كادرها الدبلوماسي من ايران لان لا يمكن
همم ابقاء الكادر وفي ظل هكذا جرائم تحدث
وايضا مشاهدنا همم نفس العمليه حدثت فيما
يتعلق ما بين السعوديه وايران ما بين
بريطانيا وما بين ايران لذلك هذا وارد جدا
ان تقوم همم اذربيجان بسحب همم كادرها
الدبلوماسي من ايران ولكن اعتقد انه
النظام الايراني سوف الان يتوقف عن هذه
الحادث وهم ببعض المناوشات على الحدود
الاذربيجانيه الايرانيه
لان كما يبدو همم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بدات تطلب من اذربيجان بالضغط
على
المركبات التي تعبر عبر الحدود للادار
بايجانيه لانها تحمل سلاح ومخدرات اشكرك
جزيلا الشكر من لندن من ضمن الينا الباحث
في الشان الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن شكرا
جزيلا
اوضح مسؤول بارز في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
روسيا تنقل حربها ضد اوكرانيا الى مرحله
مختلفه من خلال شان هجمات عشوائيه على
المدنيين والاهداف غير العسكريه المسؤول
الاوروبي انتقد في ذات الوقت تهديدات
موسكو بسبب ارسال المانيا والولايات
المتحده دبابات متطوره الى اوكرانيا مضيفا
ان روسيا تحول تركيز الحرب على الناتو
والغرب
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
او متى يشاركوا بشكل مباشر في الصراع في
اوكرانيا حضرته المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريه زخرفه من ان المواجهه بين
الناس وماسكو
في اوكرانيا تتزايد واكدت زخرفه ان ارسال
الدبابات لاوكرانيا لن يغير من واقع الحرب
وسيرفع المواجهه بين الغرب وروسيا لمستوى
اخر
رجحت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه عدم تحقيق
روسيا لاي تقدم الجوهري في مناطق قرب
دونتسبوجيا في اوكرانيا خلال الايام السته
الاخيره الوزاره اضافت ان معلقين من روسيا
نشر عبر الانترنت ادعاءات بان القوات
الروسيه حققت تقدما مهما مخترقه الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه في تلك المناطق وقالت الوزاره
ان مصادر عسكريه روسيه تنشر على ما يبدو
معلومات مضلله بشكل متعمد للايحاء بان
العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا ما زالت
تحتفظ بالزخم
اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تنفيذ هجمات
على اوكرانيا لتعطيل نقل الاسلحه
الاوكرانيه الى الجبهه بما في ذلك اسلحه
الناتو اشارت الدفاع الروسيه في بين الله
الى انها نفذتها هجمات على منشات عسكريه
للطاقه في اوكرانيا وكده البيان وانا
القوه الروسيه الحقت اضرار جسيما بمرافق
الطاقه التي تعتمد عليها مؤسسات صناعه
الدفاع ونظام النقل في اوكرانيا
ومن كيف ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عدل حذيفه مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض اريد السؤال هنا
عن ما قالته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بانها
نفدت هجمات على عدد من منشات الطاقه
ومنشات ايضا كذلك عسكريه محاوله منها
لتعطيل لنقل الاسئله الغربيه اسلحه النيته
الى داخل همم اوكرانيا ماذا لديك من
تفاصيل حول هذا البيان الروسي
نعم مساء الخير نايف يعني في الحقيقه طبعا
السلطات الاوكرانيه بشكل رسمي لم تعلق على
هذا البيان ولكن دعني اربط بينه وبين
التحديث الذي قامت به هيئه الاركان العامه
المشتركه حول عمليات القصف التي تمت في ال
24 ساعه الماضيه تعلم ان حتى وقت متاخر
للمساء امس اتم الاعلان عن 55 صاروخ
الروسيا نفذت يعني هجمات نفذت نحو الاراضي
والمدن الاوكرانيه تحديث الاخير يقول ان
ارتفعت حصيله الصواريخ التي
قامت روسيا بضربه الاراضي الاوكرانيه بها
الى 70 صاروخا لكن الرقم ما زال 55 صاروخا
اطلقت نحو المدن الاوكرانيه اي ان هذا
الفرق هو اطلق في جبهات القتال المختلفه
وعلى مواقع مختلفه في مناطق قريبه من
الجبهات قد تكون طبعا استهدفت هذه ضربات
الصاروخيه همم يعني همم مستودعات الاخيره
وغيرها ولكن لم يتم الاصلاح عن ذلك في
بيان هيئه الاركان المشتركه لقد طبعا همم
الدفاع الجوي عن اوكراني اسقط 47 صاروخا
من هذه السبعين صاروخ وطبعا ايضا ارتفعت
حصيله الضربات الاوغارات الجويه الى 44
غاره جويه همم يعني نفذت نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه طبعا كان عدد القارات 24 غار
ارتفاع الى 44 غار 18 منها كانت بطائرات
طراز شاهد وارتفعت حصيله الضربات براجمات
الصواريخ الى 125 ضربه راجمات الصواريخ
حول طبعا جبهات القتال والقتال في ال- ال-
يعني خط النار الاساسي طبعا هنالك ثلاثه
محاور رئيسيه هو محور باخدنيسك وكذلك محور
لوغاز حيث كريم وصفاته تقول قوات الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انها تحقق تقدما بطيئا نحو هذه
المدن للسيطره عليها طبعا يعيق القوات
الاوكرانيه هو همم ما يعيق القوات
البركانيه هو عمليات زرع الالغام الواسعه
النطاق في تلك المنطقه اما في باخمه
تحديدا لا تقدم للقوات الروسيه كان هنالك
طبعا عمليه قصف واسعه في تحديدا في الشاص
نيار وكذلك في اف ديفكا في افديك هنالك
قتيلين وخمسه جرحى اما في اربيل جراد
والتي يقول الاتحاد الروسي انه حقق تقدما
فيها على العكس تماما اتى بيان هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الاوكرانيه يقول ان
القوات الروسيه تتلقى خسائر كبيره في هذا
المحور دمرت ثلاث دبابات وعدد من مستودعات
الذخيره وعدد من العربات المدرعه الناقله
للجنود ولكن الاهم هو انه انها اعلنت عن
109 قتلى من الجنود الروس و188 الجريحا
فقط في هذا المحور حيث اجداد واما المحاور
الاخرى فهي فهو قتال بالمدفعيه ولا تقدم
ولا اشتباك مباشر يذكر في تلك المحاور
نايف ممتاز وانت تستاهل كذلك عن ما همم
يعني مرجحت همم وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه همم حذيفه قبل قليل بان هناك
همم معلقين من روسيا هنا بعض ال- اا
ادعاءات المضله والتي تزعم ان روسيا تقدم
تقدم يعني همم او تحقق تقدما جوهريا في
مناطق الصراع خصوصا شرق اوكرانيا في
الدونتس في زبرجيا كذلك ما هو الوضع
الميداني الحقيقي في هذه المناطق الان هل
فعلا روسيا لا تحقق تقدما في هذه المناطق
مقابل سيطره اوكرانيه حتى هذه اللحظه اما
نقلته الوزاره صحيح او وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه
نعم في الحقيقه اولا نفر ذلك الرئيسكي في
خطابه المسائي بالامس عندما تحدث عن جبهات
القتال خاصه بعد الاجتماع العام لان قاده
هيئه الاركان المشتركه العامه الذي اجتمع
بالقاده الميدانيين في الجبهات القتال
يعني لكل طبعا جزء من الجبهات يعني الجزء
الشمالي والجزء الشرقي والجنوبي ولكل قوه
مقاتله لديها قائد ميدالي هو اجتمع بهؤلاء
القاده الذين اكدوا ان الاوضاع تحت
السيطره لا تقدم يذكر للقوات
الروسيه في تلك المحاور المحور الاهم
والاشرف هو طبعا محور باخوه اكدت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه لا
تحقق في تقدم لا يوجد اي اختراق لدفاعات
القوات الاوكرانيه خاصه من اتجاه بعد ان
تراجعت قليلا القوات الاوكرانيه وقامت
بتحديد دفاعات الهندسيه الهند
كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عدل على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
نفى رئيسه مؤسسه روستير الحكوميه الروسيه
لصناعه الاسلحه سيرجي جيمز اوف نفى ان
تكون القوه الروسيه تعاني من نقص في ذخائر
المدفعيه ونقرا اعلام محلي عن جيمز اوف
قوله انما يتداوله ما يتم تداوله في كيف
شان نفاد الصواريخ والقذائف ما هو الا
كلام فارغ مضيفا ان مؤسسته زادت من انتاج
الدخيره الثرى من مره كما تمت مضاعفه
انتاج بعض الانواع بشكل ضخم بطلب من وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وفقاقه
اعلن رئيس المجموعه العلميه والانتاجيه
للهندسه الميكانيكيه الكسندر ليونوف ان
صاروخ تيركون الفرد صوتي للبحريه الروسيه
سيدخل الخدمه العام الجاري واكد ليونوف
بان مدى صاروخ سيركوني يزيد عن 900 كم لكن
هذا ليس المدى الاقصى له مشيرا الى ان
اجراءات اعتماده جاريه حيث تم انتاجه
بكميات كبيره هذا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه سابقا ان الفرقاطه ادميرال جورج
في الجزء الغربي من المحيط الاطلسي عمليه
اطلاقا لصاروخ سيركن على هدف بحري يبعد
عنها اكثر من 900 كيلو متر
لفت رئيس الوزراء المجاريب فيكتور اوربان
الى ان الدول الغربيه فقد انجرفت لمشاركه
النشطه في الصراع الذي يدور في اوكرانيا
من خلال تقديم الاسلحه والاموال وفي
مقابله مع اذاعه المجيريه قال اوروبا ان
اوروبا ان قراره المانيا بارسال 14 دبابه
من طرازيل وبارد 2 الى اوكرانيا يعتبر
رمزا للدوري الغربي المتزايد في الحرب
وادعاء اوربان الغرب الى السعي لوقف الحرب
واجراء محادثات السلام عوضا عن تسريح
اوكرانيا على حد قوله
حضر المفوضه سامي للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين فيليبو غراندي من ان تصعيد
القتال في اوكرانيا قد يؤدي الى موجه
جديده من اللاجئين وقال جراند ان الجميع
يتوقعوا ان تكون هناك زياده في الاعمال
القتاليه ومن المرجح ان يؤدي ذلك الى مزيد
من النزوح
مين
وما رايناه في الايام القليله الماضيه ليس
الابرز فالجميع يتوقع ان يكون هناك ارتفاع
في الاعمال العدائيه والمزيد من التصحيح
ومن المحتمل ان يؤدي الى مزيد من عمليه
النزوح
[موسيقى]
اعلنا مسؤولون امريكيون مقتل القيادي في
تنظيم داعش بلال السوداني في عمليه هجوميه
للجيش الامريكي شمال الصومال فيما اكد
مسؤول امريكي انه لا يوجد حتى الان اي شخص
اخر بين الصفوف عملاء داعش العالميين يمكن
ان ينافس السوداني في قدرته على تلقي
وتوزيع الاموال غير المشروعه فمن هو بلال
السوداني
بلال السوداني القيادي بتنظيم داعش
عميل رئيسي لشبكه داعش العالميه
كان مسؤول عن تشجيع الوجود المتنامل لداعش
في افريقيا
مسؤول عن تمويل عمليات التنظيم في كل
انحاء العالم بما في ذلك افغانستان
مسؤول امريكي افاد بانه ليس لداعش من
ينافس السوداني في قدرته على تلقي وتوزيع
الاموال غير المشروعه
الخزانه الامريكيه فرضت عقوبات على
السودان
شاركت سوداني في تجنيد وتدريب مقاتليين
لحركه الشباب في الصومال
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
شرطه
تلقي القبض على قاتله الممتعه في السعوديه
الرابعه تكشف التفاصيل
حياكم الله من جديد القى شرطه الامريكيه
القبضه على امراه من جورجيا على خلفيه
حادثه الطعن المميته للمبتدعه السعودي
الوليد الغريبي وكاله شرطه مدينه
من العمر 19 عاما من كولومبوس في ولايه
جورجيا محتجزه الان لديهم ووجهت اليها
تهمه القتل العمد والسرقه والسطو وجرائم
اخرى ذات اسئله
يوم الاثنين الماضي كان هذا المنزل مسرحا
لعمليات قتل رحب حياتها الطالب السعودي
وليد الغريبي لل 25 عاما قتلته نيكول ميري
الامريكيه ذي 19 عاما تفاصيل الحادث
ترويها لنا صاحبه المنزل التي وجدت وليد
غارقا في دماؤه في الطابق الثالث تحديدا
في الحمام صاحبه المنزل تم استدعائها على
عجل من قبل القاتلين الاخرين للمنزل قالوا
لها بانهم يسمعون صوت لبدات مخنوقه لا
يعرفون مصدرها وصلت صاحبه المنزل على عجل
وجدت نيكول ميري تنظف بطريقه غريبه تشاجرت
هي واياها وعلى الفور لكل ميري تركت
المنزل
دخلت الى سيارتها واقلعت
هنا صاحبه المنزل
حاولت ان تطلع على ماذا لا يحصل تحديدا في
الطابق الثالث وجدت باب الحمام مقفولا
حاولت بكل الطرق ان تفتحه وفي النهايه
نجحت
لتجديد غارقا في دماؤه في هذا الحمام
يصارع ويلفض نفس انفاسه الاخيره حاولت
الاتصال بالشرطه وبعد 10 دقائق تحديدا
وصلت الشرطه لتعلن وفاه وليد عند الساعه
11:00
صباحا 51 دقيقه
ومعنى من الرياض سلطان الغريبي عم المبدعه
المقتول في بنسلفانيا سيد سلطان عظم الله
اجركم اولا يعني حادثه مروعه مفجعه بصراحه
كل وسائل الاعلام يعني الدوليه تناقلت هذه
القصه لكن اريد الروايه من
اهل الوليد ما الذي وصلكم كيف استقبلتم
ايضا او نقل لكم هذا الخبر
والله يغفر له ويرحمه همم الخبر
تقريبا يوم الاثنين الساعه
[موسيقى]
12:00 بالليل
من شرطه بلد فيها على
[موسيقى]
ايميل
ابوه الساعه 12
طالبين فيهن
عليه التواصل معهم مشان
قضيه تخص الوليد في قسم القتل
بصراحه الايميل كان مر بك شوي لانه ما كان
في تفاصيل ولكن
[موسيقى]
تواصل معهم اتصل عليهم
فاعطوه بعض المعلومات انه ااه
الوليد تعرض
اعتدال ومن همم
فتاه همم بدون تفاصيل والكاز وكان انه
تعرض همم
ادى الى مقتله التع الى الطعام كده
بالالوان انه تعرض الى الطائف وادي الى
همم
الدكتور عبد الله على
السفاره
واعطاهم بعض المعلومات في نفس الوقت كانت
الشرطه
تواصلت مع السفاره
في نفس اليوم همم يعني تقريبا بالنسبه همم
توقيت الولايات المتحده اشتغلت السفاره
فريق الى همم
[موسيقى]
التحقيق وهمم كمال اجراءات القضيه فيها
طيب السؤال
يعني على طول حجز طبعا
الان موجود
رجع الى واشنطن بعد بعد ما انتهت
الاجراءات هناك طيب ايش اللي حصل في في
الاجراءات يعني او من التطورات او من
تفاصيل ايضا ايش الدوافع ايضا دوافع هذا
القتل اللي يطلعوها همم يعني او شافها
الولد المقتول الدكتور عبد الله
نعم وكانت
القضيه هن الفتاه كانت ساكنه معه في نفس
البنايه وفي نفس الشيه لانه الشله عباره
عن مجموعه غرف
لكل ساكن الغرفه
وفي الخدمات مشتركه مثل دورات المياه
والمطبخ وصلاه الجلوس هذه المشتركه بين
همم السكان وهي كان هو ساكن الدور الثاني
وهي في الدور الثالث
من اسبوع او اكثر
يعني مش الاسباب يعني ليش يعني كانت
مترصده لقتله منذ اسبوع
يعني محتويات
تترصد لهم بهذا الشال يعني وحسب ما يعني
صدر انه كانت همم
الغرفه لمده همم 18 يوم
ايه طبعا هي
خرج مستجيرتها
اللي هو يوم الاثنين الماضي
على الساعه
11:11 ونصف تقريبا
[موسيقى]
فلما طلع الدور الثالث اول ما طلع بس هي
كانت همم طبعا همم
مستعده بادوات
نعم جريمه
على طول مباشره
متاثر كثير
يعني
همم بنيتها طويتها سحبته
واعطيته كذا طعنات بعدين دخلته الحمام
فاجهزت عليك تماما يعني في عدد من
الطاعنات في اماكن
متعدده من جسم فقال يعني اغلقت
[موسيقى]
الحمام بالمفتاح
ثم نزلت
غرفه الوليد رحمه الله عليه
فاستولت على اغراض مثل اللي عرفتهم اااه
المتغير الى الان يعني لابسه
الموبايل
المحفظه المفاتيح
اشياء كثيره
عن الوليد يعني هو منذ متى موجود في
الولايات المتحده ومبدعه يدرس وكان يعني
يدرس رحمه الله عليه البكالوريوس
منذ سنوات
الدكتور عبد الله في الملحقيه الثقافيه
كان في صحبه
همم
ده غسل المرحله الثانويه بعد ما همم انتهت
المرحله دراسه في المرحله الثانويه هل تحق
بعد فتره انتهى عمل والد والرجعه هو باقي
هناك
واكمل دراسته وكان على وشك التخرج يمكن
كان متبقي له همم من شهرين الى ثلاث شهور
بالكثير وبعد ذلك ارجع الى السعوديه مره
اخرى الى الى اهله
اي نعم خلاص التخرج بيرجع هنا
ومتى ستصل كيف تتم ترتيبات نقل الجثه الى
السعوديه ان كانت ستنقل
هي كل الاجراءات تقريبا
انتهت من
الشرطه من السفاره ثقيل فقط شهاده الوفاه
هم ينت
ظرون يعني همم اليوم همم تصلهم
وبحكم ان هذا اليوم وهو اخر يوم عمل في
الولايات المتحده
ان شاء الله تكون ااه وصلاتهم اليوم اذا
وصلتم اليوم باذن الله همم بكره او بعد
بكره يكون
باذن الله رحمه الله عليه رحمه الله عليه
تعز الحاره مره اخرى الله يعظم اجركم
ويرحمتكم شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض سلطان
الغريب يا عم المبتعث المقتول في
بنسلفانيا الوليد الغريب شكرا جزيلا
اكمل المركز السعودي للاعمال ان شاء الله
16 فرع في مختلف المناطق حيث
سيكون لمستفيديها اكثر من 750 خدمه حكوميه
ويهدي في المركز لتوحيد تقديم الخدمات
الحكوميه لقطاع الاعمال
[موسيقى]
ومعنى هنا في الاستديو الكاتب الاقتصادي
بندر السفير سيد بندر مرحبا بك معي في
النشاط الرابع من الرياض مركز السعوديه
كيف تقيم عمل هذا المركز حتى الان ونشوف
وصل في البدايه اشكرك على الاستضافه
احييكم
لو عدنا الوراء الى خمس سنوات مثلا سالنا
جميع رجال سيدات اعمال المملكه ما اكبر
عائق لك في ممارسه الاعمال حتى من تجد انه
المرتبه الاولى في هذه التحديات انه انا
راجع 60 جهه 50 جهه عشر جهات بانظيم
وتشريعات مختلفه لها
ولا يخفى عليك ولا على الجميع عمليه سهوله
ممارسه الاعمال تعتبر هي من اصلب مؤشرات
التنافسيه في الاقتصاد مدى مرونتا مدى
تطور هذا الاقتصاد فبالتالي كانت تصنيف
المملكه في تلك الفتره قبل خمس سنوات 94
عالميا هو مرتبه لا تليق بالمملكه لذلك
وزاره التجاره ممثله يمكن المركز السعودي
الاعمال
عملت اصلاحات كثيره في ممارسه الاعمال حتى
يعني حصدت العام الماضي المركز الاول
عالميين في مستوى الاصلاحات
تحسن التصنيف من 94 الى 62
واعتقد انه لو انتظرنا الى اصدار نشره عام
22 خلال شهر شهرين يمكن تحسن احد اهداف
المركز الرئيسي طبعا انا برجع لك انا نقطه
الجهه الحكوميه بس احد اهداف المركز
الرئيسي هي زياده الايرادات غير النفطيه
يمكن هذا اساسي ورئيسي مش الي حقق المركز
من ارقام ماليه خلال خلينا نقول العام
لمصر من 2008 22
والاكدت على هذا الهدفه طبعا هذا هو هدف
واحد فقط
اهم الاهداف انه كل ما سهلت ممارسه
الاعمال زاد حجم الاقتصاد كل ما زاد حجم
الاقتصاد زاد مساهمه القطاع الخاص في
الناتج المحلي لان انا قاعد اسهل ممارسه
الاعمال حتى من هذا قاعد ينعكس على
الايرادات اللي ترد للمركز وتعزيز
للارادات الغير نفطيه وهذا طبعا مرتبط في
احد اهداف 20 30 لكن يعني الغريب في انه
هذا النوع ممارسات اول المراكز رغم انه
يحقق بعض الايرادات لكن هدف الاساسي هو
همم اختصار وقت وبعض الممارسات ترفضت
تكاليف عندما اجمع لك مجموعه من التراخيص
في ذات مثلا الاجراء في بعضها يخفض لك
هذه
التكلفه والرسوم طيب انت قبل قليل تتحدث
عن جهه حكوميه كلها موجوده في نفس المركز
هو موجود في تقريبا سبع جهات حكوميه هذا
حاليا حاليا
كافيه سبع جهات حكوميه فقط لاي ممارسه
اعمال ال- ال- كخطوه اساسيه اولى نعم
كافيه لكن هم يعملون الان على زياده كافه
الاجرائات
المركز معه تاسيس المركز خلال الاقل
مسمى مختلف في شهر ديسمبر الماضي اكمل فرع
16 على مستوى المملكه الان في منصه موحده
لقطاع الاعمال فبالتالي عمليه الممارسه
ونضج هذه التجربه تحتاج لوق اللي يمكن
المنصه تعفي الكثير يعني الان صار عندك
مركز المركز مغنى عندك المنصه فبالتالي
هذه
المركز اليوم من جهات حكوميه مفروض او
جهات ايضا مفروض انها تكون موجوده حتى
تسهل على رواد الاعمال وتختصر عليهم الوقت
مثل ما ذكرتك
امر يحتاجه هو السهوله الوصول للناس انا
متاكد انه الوصول للمستفيد لحدا يعني
المشكله
يعني همم
ان شاء الله
فبالتالي يعني هي تحتاج الى عمليات تسويق
اكثر وصول اكثر للمستفيدين حتى همم وطبعا
على فكره تفاجات انه في شركات عملاقه ايضا
مستفيده من هذه الخدمات وليست فقط رياده
اعماله صغيره متوسطه لان في خدمات مشتركه
تقوم فيها نيابه عنك ممتاز انا اشكرك جزيل
شكرا على وج معي هنا في استديو الرابعه
الكاتب الاقتصادي بندرسفير شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا لك
يعتبر الزهايمر اكثر انواع الخرب شيوعا
بنسبه تصل الى 80% بحسب دليل ممارسه الصحه
النفسيه لعام 2022 الصادر عن وزاره الصحه
السعوديه وقد اوضح الدليل بعض الحالات
المريضه وطرق التعامل معها منها مرض
الزهايمر المزيد مع
اصيب والده بمرض الزهايمر فقرر ان يكرس
وقته للعنايه به عمر العبثاني امضي 13
عاما في تقديم الرعايه لوالده تحديات
واجهها في فهمي مرض الزهايمر والتعاملي
معه لكنه سرعان ما تغلب عليها بفضل اسراره
على التثقيف الصحي عن المرض في البدايه
كانت متعبه لعدم امامي بالموضوع كانت كل
محاولات لتقديم الرعايه لوالدي كانت
محاولات
تبتسم بالعشوائيه كنت
بتجربه عده طرق وكنت اختار منها التجربه
الجيده في الحصول على افضل النتائج 23
عيادات استحدثها تجمع الشرقيه لرعايته
كبار السن في مجمع الدماغ الطبي وشبكه
القطيف المركزيه ومستشفى الرعايه المديده
بالظهران استفاده منها حتى الان نحو 320
مستفيدا منهم ما يقاربوا 40% يحملون اعرا
المرادي الذاكره او من يشتبه في اصابتهم
بمرض الزهايمر من دون انطلاقتها خلال
العام تقريبا تم تسجيل 320 موعد
يشكل 40% تقريبا بشكل تقريبي من مستفيدين
ممن لديهم امراض ذاكره او اعراض لها علاقه
بمرض الزهايمر التوسعه في تقديم الرعايه
لكبار السن منهم مصابي مرض الزايمر شمل
تقديم الاستشارات من خلال العيادات
الافتراضيه وتفعيل المواعيد الافتراضيه
لتسهيل على المرضى ومرافقهم حرص تجمع
الشرقيه الصحي على توفير نوعيه ذات جوده
لهذه العيادات ابتداء من مده موعد يتراوح
من 30 الى 45 دقيقه ايضا من خلال تفعيل
المواعيد الافتراضيه للتسهيل التواصل مع
المرضى او مرافقينهم خدمات صحيه تقدمها
وزاره الصحه السعوديه لمن يعانون من امراض
الذاكره ومنها الزهايمر من خلال التشخيص
المبكر لتدمير العلاج الامثل وتقييم
الاعراض الجسديه المصاحبه وع كذلك تقييم
الاعراض النفسيه والسلوكيه وتقديم التثقيف
الصحي للمستفيدين والمرافقين على كيفيه
التعامل مع المرض من المنطقه الشرقيه علي
اللغبي العربيه
ومعنا هنا في الاستديو استشاري طب الاعصاب
والامراض العصبيه وعضو جمعيه الزهايمر
الدكتور فواز ابراهيم دكتور فواز حياك
الله يرحمه مرحبا اهلا وسهلا فيك
الزهايمر هو اشد واكثر انواع الخرف شيوعا
في العالم مش ادق تعريف اولا ال سهم تعريف
مختصر
قناه العربيه على الاستراحه همم طبعا
الزهايمر هو عباره عن مشاكل في الادراك
همم تبتدئ عاده بمشكله في الذاكره قصيره
المدى
مع الوقت همم تنتقل الى وظائف الدماغ
الاخرى وبعد فتره زمنيه معينه يحصل همم
مشاكل الوظيفه وبالتالي همم
يحصل تدهور ادراكي وتدهور وظيفي يؤدي همم
الى همم الى مشكله الزهايمر فهو عباره عن
مرض عصبي انت سي ممتا يصيب مناطق معينه في
الدماغ مسؤول عن الذاكره
وبسبب الترسب بروتين سام هذا البروتين
يعمل على همم يعمل على ضمور في تلك
المناطق المسؤوله عن الوظيفه وعن ادراك
نعم صحيح في الاحصائيات همم انه كلتا ثلاث
ثواني وصاب شخص في العالم صحيح بهذا المرض
بمعنى انه كل عام احنا لدينا قرابه 10
ملايين شخص يصابون بالزعيمر صحيح ادعي على
مستوى العالم لكن اسالك عن السعوديه في
اخر تقرير واحصائيه موجوده على صفحتكم انه
عدد المصابين بهذا المرض المرض الخرف اللي
هو الزهايمر في السعوديه 130,000 اولا هل
نزل هذا الرقم بهذا الشكل وهل تتطور مع
السنوات مع زياده الاعداد السكانيه في
السعوديه الكثافه السكانيه صحيح هو هو
عالميا مرض الزهايمر همم كل سنه يكون هناك
همم تقريبا 10 مليون مصعب على مستوى
العالم بالتالي كل ثلاث ثواني اا يصاب شخص
واحد في العالم على مستوى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لا توجد هناك احصائيات دقيقه
لعدد المصابين بمرض الزهايمر ولكن همم
التقديرات الاوليات تشير الى عدد قريب من
150,000 مصاب ناخذ بالاعتبار همم انه همم
ليس كل المصابين ياتون للمستشفيات همم
للفحص يعني هناك مصابين همم الزهايمر لم
يتم همم فحصهم حتى الان بسبب همم يعني همم
المجتمع يحتاج ان يعرف الى اعراض الزهايمر
ايش هو اهم اعراض طبعا هو بالبدايه
الزهايمر همم يكون يتاثر بالعمر
65 يكون عدد المصابين يقارب الخمسه بالمئه
همم تزداد هذه النسبه همم كل خمس سنوات
يكون تدبل النسبه الى ان تصل ااا بالنسبه
بعمر 85 سنه يصل نصف اللي اعمارهم 85 سنه
مصابين بالزهايمر يعني نصف الي عمارهم 85%
في السعوديه مصابين بالتقريبا يعني بعد سن
ال 85 من 30 الى 50% من الاشخاص اللي
اعمارهم فوق 85 مصابين همم
بامراض الادراك من ضمنها الزهايمر لانه
الزهايمر يمكن شيوعا طيب انت همم قبل قليل
ذكرت بانه لا يذهبوا الى الفحص وانت ماذا
كارت من اول ما يعني تحدث عن موضوع عن
العلاج
هل معناه انه
استعصى على الاطباء علاج
هو اكثر من 120 سنه خلال 120 سنه لم يتم
اكتشاف الا عدد بسيط من الادويه
الحاله ولكن لا تعمل على ازاله المشكله من
من اساسها
تقريبا قبل شهر قبل شهر تقريبا همم في
علاج همم
تم فسحه في امريكا وهو يعالج الحالات همم
في بدايتها يعني الزهايمر في بدايته يعمل
على همم يعمل على تبطيء التدهور بنسب 27%
وهو لا زال محور وليس ايقاف ليس ايقاف لا
يوجد علاج للايقاف الزهايمر حتى اشكرك
جزيلا شكرا ان شاء الله بالسلامه لكل
المصابين الله احب فقط
عندنا اجتماع جمعيه الزهايم الخامس في
الرياض تحت همم
بزياره كريمه من سيدي همم صاحب همم سمو
امير منطقه الرياض وهي فرصه للجميع للحضور
والتسجيل بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء الله
العربيه استشاري طب الاعصاب والامراض
العصبيه ثالثه ثانوي ابراهيم شكرا شكرا
السعوديه رئيسه للجنه التراث العالمي بعد
اعلان اعتمادها من منظمه الامم المتحده
للتربيه والعلم والثقافه يونسكو التي
اعلنت ايضا اعتمادها قرار استضافه العاصمه
الرياض
لاجتماع لجنه التراث العالميه المتضمنه 21
دوله في العاشر من سبتمبر المقبل ولمده 15
يوما
ومعنا من فريق سلمان
اليونسكو الاميره هيفاء
حياك الله معنا اميره في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض سعيدين اولا بوجودك معنا مبروك
طبعا اول لكم هذا الاعتماد واسال ماذا
يعني لكم اعتماد السعوديه رئيسه لهذه
اللجنه لجنه التراث العالمي
شكرا جزيلا للاخير حاليا باستضافه
وبالتاكيد همم يعني سعداء جدا وفخورين بان
المملكه سوف تستضيف نجاه التراث العالمي
لهذا العام طبعا هذه اللجنه هي من اهم
اللجان الموجوده في منظمه الامم المتحده
للتربيه والثقافه والعلوم وهي تعنى بتسجيل
المواقع التراثيه ذات القيمه الاستثنائيه
العالميه حول العالم همم طبعا هذه اتفاقيه
من عام 1972 السعوديه طبعا عضو فيها همم
هذه اللجنه ايضا تتابع حسن اداره تسجيل
هذه المواقع طبعا تسجيل المواقع لماذا ليس
له هذه الاهميه الكبيره لانه طبعا كثير من
الناحيه الثقافيه من الناحيه ال- اا
السياحه من ناحيه الوظائف همم كثير من
الدول تعطي كثير من الاهميه لهذه
الاتفاقيه همم هذه اللجنه تضم 21 دوله يتم
انتخابها همم
يكون في فتره اربع سنوات والمملكه همم
امضت ثلاث سنوات في هذه المنظمه همم والان
في هذه الاتفاقيه وهذه اللجنه همم والان
هذه السنه الرابعه التي سوف تستضيف فيها
مملكه همم
اعتماد اي دوله السعوديه او اي دوله اخرى
في ان يتم اعتمادها كرئيسه لهذه اللجنه
لجنه التراث العالم
طبعا تكون هذه الدوله عضو في الاجناس
اثناء اللجنه التي مدتها اربع سنوات وايضا
الدوله التي لا يكون لديها طبعا تاريخ في
الحفاظ على التراث همم دوله تكون دوله
نظيفه ومستضيفه يكون لديها الامكانيه
والقدره همم للاستضافه همم لا يحتاج
الموضوع للتذكير لدينا ثلاث سنوات لم يتم
فيها اجتماع هذه اللجنه بشكل حضوري كان في
اسباب صحيه وايضا كانت هنالك اسباب سياسيه
منحت من هذه الاجتماعات ولكن ولله المملكه
نجحت في وبالتزكيه وبالاجماع في الاستضافه
وبدون منافس
للحصول على هذه الاسترخاء الحصول احنا
نعرف انه في مواقع تراثيه السعوديه كثير
سجلت في التراث العالمي في اليونسكو لكن
السعوديه اليوم بعد ان اصبحت هي رئيسه هذه
همم اللجنه هل سيمنح هذا الاعتماد
السعوديه فرصه ان تسجل المزيد من المواقع
التراثيه العالميه في السعوديه يسهل
المهمه انجازات التعبير
بالتاكيد حسن
الملفات التي يتم تقديمها هي المحاكم
الاكبر ملفات المملكه التي يتم اعتمادها
همم تاتي بعد اعداد طويل وبعده محافظه
كبيره من جميع الجهات الوطنيه وبالتاكيد
بتوجيهات مباشره
من سمو وزير الثقافه همم وهذا هو المحكي
الاكبر خلينا نقول السبب الاكبر في تسجيل
المواقع الاستضافه بالتاكيد يعطي وزن اكبر
همم ولكن همم مبدا الحياتيه ايضا هذا يعني
البرنامج على تسجيل مواقع ولكن بالتاكيد
يعطي الفرصه للدول لرؤيه ما تفعله المملكه
ليزور المواقع التراثيه في المملكه وحسن
الاداره للمواقع هذه في المملكه الوظائف
المجتمعات المحليه وكل ما الكنوز التي لا
تلد المملكه لمشارتها مع العالم واكيد هذا
هو اسمه الكبير في اعطاء الصوره للمملكه
للوفود الموجوده
وشكرا جزيلا لك على
قبول الدعوه
وتواجدك معنا في نشره الرابعه من باريس
المندوب الدائم السعوديه لدى اليونسكو
الاميره هيفاء شكرا لك شكرا جزيلا
استشهدوا الدرعيه اليوم وغدا منافسات جوله
الفورميلائي الدرعيه للموسم الحالي وتشمل
الجوله سباقين في الموسم التاسع لبطوله
العالم لهذه المنافسات والتي تمتاز بانها
الوحيد التي تقام تحت الاضواء الكاشفه في
الليل في المسابقات الدوليه للموسم الحالي
ضمن الفورميلائي ويمتد مسار الحلبه في
الدرعيه لمده كيلو مترين و490 متر
الفجر نوع من انواع الفطر البري يظهر في
الصحراء بعد سقوط الامطار بسبع يوم هذه
نبته الموسميه يبحث عنها عشاقها في كل
مكان وتخلق حراكا اقتصاديا كل شيء ثاني
[موسيقى]
9600 800 900 10,000 ريال هكذا تتعالى
اصوات البائعين في تظاهره الموسميه
تحتضنها محافظه رفحاء بمنطقه الحدود
الشماليه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
الكما او ما يعرف محليا بالفجاع نبته
الموسميه خلقت حركه اقتصاديا في كل شتاء
اسعار الفقع قد لا يحدها سقف امام اقبال
كبير للظفر بها البوابه الاولى
منطقه الشمال الاسعار عندنا هنا
15 يوم تقريبا
بالنسبه للشريطيه المملكه كلها متواجدين
امس حقيقه تجاوز 360,000 ريال امس كان فيه
الطلب اكثر من العرض وجميع الاسواق اللي
شغاله الان في المملكه كلها المصدر هناك
من يرى بان الكما لا يظهر مبكرا بهذا
الحجم وانما يحتاجه بعضا من الوقت ليصل
الى ذروته ولكن المختصين هناك في هذا
السوق الشعبي يرونكس ذلك
يقول لنا الفقع مستورد وانا اكد على
الجميع 100% بحيثكم خبرتي اكثر من 20 سنه
الفقع محلي 100% وانا مسؤول عن كلامي هذا
فقع محلي
وما مزارع ما جانب رفحاء مزارع موجود
والمزارع اغلى من اللي فقع الجينا الميزان
كيلو 1200 ريال احنا الكيلو عندنا 750
ريال الفقعوا النادر من انواع الفطر يظهر
في الصحراء بعد سقوط الامطار ب70 يوما وله
انواع عده من اشهرها واغلىها ثمنا الزبيدي
ذو اللون الابيض الرائحه القويه ثم
الغلاسه الذي يتميز بلونه البني المائل
للاحمرار اما اقلها انتشارا فالجباء بلونه
البني الداكن من محافظه رفحاء جزاعا مصير
العربيه
ختام الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
اذربيجان تصف الهجوم على سفرتها بالارهابي
وتتهم ايران بتجاه لدعواتها لتعزيز امن
السفاره
روسيا تاكد استهدافها اسلحه غربيه وشنه
هجمات مكثفه على البنت تحتيه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا
في الامريكيه تلقي القبض على قاتله
السعودي الرابعه تكشف التفاصيل
اسواق الفقع شمال السعوديه تشهد اقبالا
واسعا حجم المبيعات يقدر ب 100.000
شكرا لكم
مزيد من الاخبار والمعلومات نهايه الرابعه
اعود والقاكم غدا في رعايه
[موسيقى]